voodoo
astero bored to
do その後は東京大学の大学院に入学し
マスター pou dou
dou 愛の後あースタンフォード大学院
に入りました今もう山ほどで博士号の研究
をしています博士号
だっぺぱちゃんっていうか東大と
スタンフォード大学って普段から英語を
教えていると思うんだけど多分普通に僕の
日本語のおかしいところも治せるね入って
きますよ
本題に入る前に何かいいましょうか
re
astero
sper serve as
onerror 東京に住んでたんですが
そこで見たアパートは全部外国人 ok
でしたねやっぱそうだよね僕もそうだった
でも私の留学生が友達で埼玉に死んでいる
人がいてその人はダメやっぱ言ってもらっ
ていい
何を矢先僕の日本語のおかしいところも
普通に直せるねって言ったんだけどそれ
冗談だったんだ僕の日本語ネイティブと
ほぼ変わらないからねだからさノアが
さらっと言ったうんできますよ何個海洋
かっていう発言がめっちゃ日かかるって
言うか
のに道元さんって本当にいそう思ってるん
ですか思ってるっていうか普段からそう
言われてるから日本には相手を立てる文化
があるんですがご存知でしょうか日本人で
も知らないポン子だっていっぱい知ってる
し博士号とかですかじゃあどこがおかしい
か教えてはまず無線歯茎硬口蓋破擦音
だろうかc ですねー夢精しキュアボイス
peroon ボイス p パワー
future 日本語ビーカー一番最初に
日本語で言いましたよ道元さんがわから
ないピュアフェイ be sure do
do もまあまあ編 sai ティーザー
wii l 4スパーカーターズ4 s の
superfine ファイターは俺と
夢精両親摩擦も許すメイキングウィズア
ペティスポ0